you're now live chair
thank you very much indeed and it is six
o'clock exactly
so um i would like to welcome you all to
this virtual meeting
of external overview and scrutiny on the
14th
of october and i will go through
just some of the basic rules for this
meeting
the start of the meeting we will mute
all microphones except for mine
which i am the chair of this committee
and please leave all microphones muted
unless instructed
by me we will unmute each counselor
officer or member of the public's
microphone individually when it's
their turn to speak
there will be the normal public
participation item at the start of the
meeting
residents who want to exercise this
right have been asked to register one
clear day in advance
of the meeting and have had the option
of sending a statement to us and which
will
read by an officer or have been sent to
a link
to temporarily join the meeting to speak
in person
once they have finished speaking they
will be removed as a participant in the
movement
and can view and listen via youtube
we have i think one or possibly two
people i know they didn't register
uh one day in advance but there's been a
fair amount of discussion going on and i
would beg the committee to allow them to
speak in the public participation slot
tonight
if you have listened to the coasters now
if you have a declaration of interest
please let me know clearly at the start
of the item
this will be noted for the minutes and
if it is a personal interest
you'll need to leave the meeting you'll
be placed in the virtual waiting room
whilst the matter is discussed
you'll be brought back to the virtual
main meeting when the
particular item is over
to indicate to me that you would like to
speak or propose
or second emotion press the raise the
hand symbol
in the participants menu on screen
these are shown on my screen in order
that they are pressed
and i will deal with them in order
giving the appropriate officer or
counselor the opportunity to answer in
between
where necessary i will also
return to the council to check that they
are happy with the response
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
the virtual meeting all votes will be
cast
by a verbal recorded vote and the names
will be read out alphabetically in
an alphabetical order please state your
book
clearly and slowly when your name is
read out
if the meeting becomes in court due to a
technical or connection issue the
meeting will be paused until the issue
is rectified
if the matter cannot be rectified and
the meeting remains in court the meeting
will be adjourned
until a new date is set
please remember that to ensure full
transparency with democratic processes
meeting is being live streamed
to your council's youtube channel
we are in unprecedented times and i ask
you to be all patient during this
meeting and to understand the processes
and advice may take a little longer than
usual
we will now have a role call can all
cursors please erase their
hand symbol
shall i procedure yes i think i got
replied raised hands but i think the six
raised hands now
shall i read the names out yes please
then okay
councillor lankin president
councillor ford rosen councillor
councillor leather
cancel a leather
counselor you're muted
here i am thank you councillor mckenzie
no he's not with us mary he's not with
us okay thank you
councillor newton yes mary i'm here
thank you councillor pennington here
and mr topham i'm here thank you
thank you okay thank you for
that uh we now move to the agenda and
uh item number one which is apologies
for absent mary any apologies
chair i've not received any apologies
thank you very much
we moved to agenda item number two which
is confirmation of the minutes held on
the 2nd of september 2020
and first of all we will go for accuracy
and then we'll pick up any matters
arising so i am on the
um bottom of the page page
three
i'm looking for any raised hands page
four
page five page
six page seven
page eight page nine
page ten
so can i have a proposer and a second or
i see no race i've got a proposer in
country newton secondary councilor
hawkins
can i take a vote on the accuracy please
mary can you take the vote yes chair um
councillor coddle honking
ford or council harding
or councillor hawkins
or councillor langford
for council leather or
councillor newton or
councillor pennington or mr topham
abstain thank you chair that's
eight four and one abstention okay
does any member wish to pick up any
matters arising not in the
uh minutes that we're gonna come on to
an agenda item four in a second
or it's not gonna come up in the forward
plan can i just see if anybody
wants to raise anything in those minutes
to ask any questions
can i just pick up one um i know
that on page 10 um
that we had uh proposed that our january
meeting was to involve the cab
um um and employment issues
and it's not on the forward plan for
january the 20th so
that is we've got a blank space on our
forward plan
and that i think just needs to be
uh correlated across to that point of
view so seeing as there's no other
matters arising we will then move on
i don't see any hands up no nobody's
raising any amount of rising so
therefore we go to
item number four which is
the i got action list is the item number
four
but um obviously we go to item number
three which is public
participation public contributions now i
have
um i think is it one or two um
guys with me this evening who would like
to speak
you can just indicate um
right we've got mr and i with us yes
yep um and is there anybody else there
in the
anybody else tom indicated they would
like to speak the scene no
um i don't know if connor's with ben but
there's no one else in the waiting room
no one else is in the way okay
well welcome uh mr nye to the meeting um
uh i think um we've had some emails in
exchange with connor prior in
preparation to this meeting and
it's trying to find a way forward um
the situation is that we're inviting you
to come to the meeting now and and
put the uh points of view across that
you would like as a member of torridge
and the value you bring to toric which i
i
hear is tremendous although i have not
been to your institution for uh many a
time
and the rule is you have three minutes
okay to put the matter across
um the committee are not allowed to
discuss it but
uh i'm sure you'll find a situation
whereby at least we can point you in a
direction
um of how to go forward in the best way
that taurus can support what is
happening
and in one sense this is an introduction
into trying to work
with the wider um cultural sector to
to be which has been so badly hit
um with the pandemic like we are so when
you're ready if you put your thumb up
and i'll put my
timer on i just got to get the timer
going here
um so yeah i'm ready
you're ready yep tom have you got a
timer there
yeah i can do chair one second okay i'm
ready to go as well so
you're ready tonight and i'm going to
ask you to
i'm going to start the clock no okay so
i think the palladium is a really
important to our local community
um because we're the only thing
in our music venue grassroots within a
60 mile radius um and we're supporting
people from their
sort of bedrooms all the way up through
from practice rooms
to jam space you know meeting
um you know like-minded people to form
bands which then got on to do
more important you know bigger gigs and
stuff um and i could also let them have
their first experience on stage
um but all the you know all the comments
i've had from people
has literally been it's more of a
community thing as well as a music venue
um so it brings people like-minded to
you know
together in one space which they
wouldn't normally get
and there's so many events grassroots
music venues closing around the country
i mean we had 558 gigs last year
um you know which is massive for the
local community
and it's bringing people from a wider
range as well so it's also
you know supporting shops and cafes and
all that sort of thing
locally so you know we're trying to push
it bigger as well with working with the
big sheep
to try and do bigger events to try and
bring people
you know music live music back to devon
and
which has sort of been missing a little
bit there's been sort of more commercial
stuff but it's more the grass roots and
giving those people
the chance to have the time on stage um
and yeah there's not really many places
like that
and you know i'm just trying to give
that as much as i can
um yeah that's pretty much it
guys okay thank you very much you've
done it one minute and 40 seconds
so um take it from there can i just ask
what help you're looking for how we can
help you how you feel today can help you
with it i mean there is
it's really tough i mean obviously
financially is is the main thing
um but even if it was you know to get us
into a space that we could actually
physically use
because at the moment because of the way
that the the inside is worked out
it just isn't viable for socially
distancing
you know we're literally not even open
at all for anything
um you're saying the situation's under
pressure basically
it's massively yeah i mean i put all my
personal
personal money into it and i've borrowed
off family and stuff
and it's just we're literally you know
the last bit now where we just
can't do it it is going to close if we
can't get some type of funding
okay i hear what you're saying um and
thank you very much for your
contribution
um no then um it sounds a little harsh
so we're not allowed as committee to
actually discuss
can i just have a bit of guidance from
our officers um how i can respond to
what mr nye has said
i'm looking to either stacy or sean here
to take
any positive forward
i suppose chair is dependent upon um how
members want to proceed on it and
and and depending upon and what
assistance
mr knight is seeking i mean if it's
alternative premises
i suppose we could look into that
potentially if it's financial that would
be
the community and resources committee um
but potentially full council as well
so um i think just to explain mr nye
um all our committees are public
committees so public's obviously allowed
to attend and comment
and i think the difficulty with
tonight's meeting is although you've
um spoken in public contributions there
was no notice of that
to the the general public um so we're
really quite
stuck when it comes to items that
weren't specifically on a committee
agenda
and but i hope you can appreciate that
that that's why we do it
because our meetings are our public so
please don't think uh
uh us rude and we will certainly feed
you your comments back
um um depending upon what how members
want to proceed
seed with it thank you then as chair we
will certainly um
if you can stay with us on the meeting
on uh whether you stay in this meeting
come back on youtube
um there will be uh the later agenda or
for
plan and i think one of the issues that
may come up for our discussions
would be the impact of covet and
certainly i would point you to our
january meeting
which we are trying to involve the cab
and other agencies
um that are dealing with the effects of
culvert and
there's many uh families out there that
are really struggling at all levels of
our society
and we have penciled that in as a
meeting agenda for the 20th of january
at 6 p.m
um but um certainly um i i've emailed
your
your colleague connor um this afternoon
that i should
be like to come and meet you guys and
have a discussion with you
and i've copied cheryl in our lead for
culture community and leisure
did you get that email cheryl earlier
this afternoon
yeah i did thank you i was wondering if
we could refer it to um full council as
stacy mentioned it
um so that more
all of the members of the council would
be able to hear from
ben nye and maybe if we could show the
video that he was planning to
present for well certainly as a
committee i think we can circulate the
video
if uh if the mythic is agreement um but
that would be
uh a a question for david brenton who is
chair of the council to consider not
myself um um if you
feel the committee feel we're not
allowed to discuss actually now at the
present moment
um so we need to go forward to the
forward plan so i can't actually
i think i'll correct the saying stacy um
must bring the conversation here just to
an end of the present moment
but wait till we get the forward plan to
work out how we can take this issue
forward
that discussion elliot didn't we
counselor pennington and actually if
you're in contact with mr nye then
you could discuss how best to proceed
with that in the future and
and you know for it to be discussed by
committee if it's an agenda
item um i think specifically um
i'm not clear at the moment as to what
committee would go to because i'm not
clear on
what whether we're discussing covert as
a whole or or
in specific um circumstances here
okay well let's just say something
could i just could i yes newton okay i
apologize for butting in um
i i'm not sure this one is for us we're
too ponderous and
and and two will be too long um by the
time we can actually look at it
um bash it around and come up with a
proposal that against council
uh this this organization will have long
since gone under
um i propose that he should
be pointed towards a sponsor um i'm
thinking
of councillor cottle hunkin possibly uh
who might then like to introduce
something through a native summation
route
um where possibly we could get something
moving more quickly by
uh inputting into council um once
we can have a clear understanding of
what it is they need
um but i fear that our process through
this committee might be
too lengthy and not quick enough for him
thank you i accept your comment i'm not
going to take your vote because it's not
right to take a vote on the
constitutional ways we must proceed and
so i'm going to close it now but we will
follow up to with you mr nye certainly
uh
um cheryl call hunkam myself
for following your comments this evening
and then try to find a path forward and
thank you very much for your
contribution
thank you very much for letting me speak
and um i i
my heart goes out to to to um
the opportunities you're giving and the
opportunities are being lost um like
many
really struggling at this present time
so thank you very much indeed
thank you i move on now to the
uh action list that you have on
a page is 11 and a 12.
the whole list of actions here let's
just begin
at minute 25
right
now then it's gelled with us this
evening guys minute 25 i am chair
uh i can update on that i do actually
have a list um i just need to touch base
with with mary about how best to
circulate that because uh the sister
there's
we have a new system it would appear and
it confused me somewhat so i've got a
list ready to go
and so i'll send that out by the
appropriate means as soon as i can do
that
thank you uh minute seven um
let us thanks to uh virginia pearson um
i think mary has done that and i
apologize to mary for not getting back
to her
to confirm that it's been sent to the
meeting so mary that's done i take it
yes yes chair it is i'll wait for your
approval to send it out
then i will read it tomorrow morning
thank you
uh urgent button on it i do apologize uh
we're doing no problems
yeah then minute seven is um
they brought forward church viewers car
park
going to afford to copy a letter to from
state spokes to the planning economy
manager
can you update me either councillor ford
or
sean carney please
yeah councillor force raised his hand
chair right council ford
yeah i'll try to keep this brief then
what i will say is i have got a meeting
actually
shortly down at apple rule which is very
important on
tuesday coming which i think uh the uh
chief exec
uh sean uh and the leader of
ken james but briefly um because
obviously
at the last meeting i was quite
aggressive
which i don't always wish to be but make
it
simple here i did i did send the letter
and i did ask recently for any
correspondence of communication between
stagecoat and
porridge i was sent things that were
five years old
when actually there was a meeting
between stagecoat 18 months ago and
uh both a male and female officer at
riverbank
resulting in the yellow box being
painted or whatever for coaches only i
mean it is a nightmare down at ecuador
and that's not an understatement
and what i did say and i did speak
actually
and i don't want this to get out of van
but i did actually double check
with the secretary there i did get it
right it's not included on the minutes
but i think some other countries might
remember there was a statement
uh sean county's response and i'd like
this no minute i was not happy with
where he referred to if any accidents
happen
because cultures are going too fast no
there might have been a historic problem
with that and i don't dispute that years
ago
coaches can't do it go too fast at the
moment in that car park because it can't
bloody well get in there to turn
and with that i'll leave it okay
so so sean kearney can you put a
response to that if you
you obviously involved in the situation
as well
yeah of course chair i mean you know to
respond to council ford's point there i
mean
if if if that was what i said i i
apologize because uh to be honest a very
inaccurate statement i mean
there could be a whole range of reasons
for an accident in a car
one of them could be speed there could
be a range of other things we have had
historic issues
with coaches going too fast in the car
park we've addressed that with
stagecoach
i did send those historic messages to
councillor ford
we have a number of other emails
between ourselves and stagecoach that
i've asked
our parking admin team to look at but
they've been a bit tied up trying to
sort out the free parking in bits and
pieces at the moment so when we get to
that we'll uh
we'll be sure to inform councillor ford
i i wasn't aware
and you know i can't suppose i can't be
aware of everything but
i wasn't aware that there'd been a
meeting between a lady and a gentleman
stagecoach to get a sign erected
um i could find out what that was about
i
i just hope that rather than looking
backwards we can meet
on tuesday or whenever it is next week
and uh look at what the issues are and
try and find some solutions so
yeah i hope for a positive outcome so
there's a meeting in hand
uh sure um christian ford you will be
attending that meeting
yeah yeah thanks for that and you're
right okay this is not about me
making myself ill and whatever and
getting aggressive i'm here to represent
the whole of toleration obviously
specifically on certain issues obviously
the people of ecuador
and i would say this by fear of
contradiction
i do not think for one moment there's
another district councillor
that walks their patch even if it's from
public pub
but sees the village of the area they
represent more than i do
i don't think anybody can actually
question that nobody can question my
um resolve my integrity or whatever
there are big issues i want this to go
forward
but yes uh please understand if i say
there was a meeting which there was
similar facts february 2019 between two
officers of toy
can i okay i mean we have the meeting on
tuesday you're going to the meeting on
tuesday
um history has taken place can i ask
that you go to that meeting of feedback
to us at our next committee please
councillor ford
um how the progress is going on because
we don't want to nobody wants any
accidents at all and we
we and the tourists certainly wouldn't
want that to happen i know
um so can i have your agreement that we
can move forward
um and you feed us back because there is
action taking place
at the meeting on tuesday
well i hope he agrees but um um i did
ask him
you would agree i'd say
in the absence of councillor ford i mean
if counselor ford can't
uh make the meeting for any reason i
will certainly feedback on the
outcomes of the meeting um please
include council
i'm sure you will um mr officer kearney
because uh
it's uh um something is quite a hot
topic there in africa thank you for that
right back in the meeting now chair okay
uh closer forward sorry we lost you
all right yes i say
you lucky no we didn't do it
deliberately
no hey hey me i'm not suspicious at all
happy days
happy days okay thank you thank you very
much indeed
can we go to minute eight um and we've
got quite a few note coming up on the
play open strategy which we
have as you know now arranged an
extraordinary meeting on the 18th of
november
to look at the revised draft um we
can we take uh did they play all the uh
next one two three four minutes were
they
is there anything we need to action
today or can they wait until we actually
have the meeting on the
um 18th of november
sean can you lead us yes of course yeah
don't you know
i was i was hoping that we would collate
everything and bring it to that
extraordinary meeting that's almost
exclusively
uh intended to debate play so we've got
a whole session we can go through it
liberally attending i'm looking there at
the uh
we haven't asked no we haven't asked
tivoli to attend yet i don't know
um i mean the meeting we've got is to
talk about the play strategy and moving
forward obviously we can pick up the
items that you wanted in the action list
um for information i'm not sure that
there's much value to be added
asking our contractor to come to that
meeting this is this is about what you
want for the future
committee are you happy with that
response from our officer
please indicate if you're not sure could
i
yes cursor leather thank you well the
two things i wanted
because of the paucity of that report we
had last time on the
play strategy and the fact that a
contract had been given to tivoli
with regard to this that's why i asked
those two questions about
exactly what there was supposed to be
work they were supposed to be doing in
that contract
and also what they've been paid for
doing that piece of work now
i'm i'm happy to leave it until we have
that that special extraordinary meeting
but i do
need an answer for both of those
questions at some stage sure
right thank you that was very clear and
very uh good advice
um
yeah okay
to come back on council at this point if
i might we we will
endeavor to provide counselor leather
and answer that question at the next
meeting
coach another is that okay to you to get
an answer or do would you like to
believe
are you i don't like the word endeavor
well
we will we will then check sorry i'll
give you
okay so can i have your agreement that
we've dealt with that uh particular
minute at the bottom
on top bottom page 11 top of page 12.
yeah chris is that happy with you i'm
finally adventure
okay yeah sorry counselor colonel
honking would like to speak yeah
currently honking please um i was just
gonna say that um
adrian avery has sent me through um
more of the draft and it had like the
audit of all of the play areas so there
is a lot
that's been done that we didn't see at
the last meeting um
just to give a little bit of reassurance
so chip
to chair if i might i mean i didn't try
and explain that last meeting i mean
obviously
the last strategy was just a working
draft it was a starting point
there was a whole load of background
information that had been circulated
some circulated previously some not
circulated at all
um that wasn't the extent of the work
that had been done i have to say
adrian's been working really hard
to get a better document to you um so it
i'm sure you'll be much happier with
what's presented to you in november
midi how are you happy just to indicate
i don't want to take a vote
whether we can deal with that yeah good
thank you very much indeed
yes didn't see any objections so
yeah then we have uh go on to minute
nine to confirm the extraordinary
meeting time
and that has been now confirmed at 2 p.m
that's been completed
and the four plan um and
we are the liaise with invitees at the
meeting of the 20th of january 2021.
um i've not talked to you sean about
that i need to talk to you about that
can we agree that we're going to talk
about that in the coming days
what's gerry right any other questions
on the forward plan
nobody indicating thank you very much
right we now go forward
to declarations of interest agenda item
number five you
all know the rules um then we see where
it goes from there
um action uh agenda item number six
agreement of agenda items part one and
two no part two tonight so we don't need
to take a vote there
um number seven the urgent matters
brought forward with the permission of
the chair
um i was contacted over the weekend
by a very concerned community it's
regarding
very similar to the public speaker ben
nye this evening
and it refers to a public house that
i've made a call in on
the public houses significant immunity
to a village
and they seek to go to residential
accommodation
um and i also know of another public
house within my own war that's been
advertised on the market as well so we
are aware
of a huge agenda um going on
in the cultural and hospitality sectors
at the present moment
are trying to keep up with the news that
comes out of westminster
since the united
that for the states planned later on
whether you would
like to match that into january the 20th
meeting
so i used bring that forward as an
urgent matter
because of all the things that have been
developing in the last few days
within our rural communities does
anybody else as a character have an
urgent matter okay
newton newton
christian newton yeah just just on your
last one chair
i we've we've we've touched on this
before
is that something that we can have any
influence over and
and therefore um should we be actually
discussing it
because um i'm not sure that
it's something that we necessarily can
have any influence over is it
well if if there is amenities that
actually
uh when it looks at the village and is
mentioned in the north dakota's local
plan
and an owner of immunity feels that they
can no longer continue in business
and we're external ons committee um that
should be influencing and trying to
change uh situation for the benefit of
our residents
um then i think that um i would argue
um that i would like to see it on the
agenda if you as a committee decide not
to bring it on the floor plan
i listen to you as a committee because
you will make that decision when it
comes forward
um but given the amount of emails i've
received in the last five or six days
on this particular item it is certainly
uh
possibly a coaster call for action which
i don't think we do very often in this
council
or um something that i would like as a
counselor to put on the forward plan
um i use that uh as urgent matters
bought fire by the chairman permission
the chair
and i offer that to any counselor at the
same time so
um i as a counselor use that prerogative
to bring it forward i offer you
if you want to bring sword that you feel
is important that it does affect your
award
and if you decide not to bring it on to
the agenda and the forward plan
then it gets lost and that's for us to
decide whether we want
to or not bring it on but we've got to
bring the agenda up first before we can
reject it
and that's where i start from yeah okay
i'll get you on it
okay any others on bringing in urgent
matters
none good yeah you've got to have nicole
honking and counsellor ford
sorry councillor colonel hogan was first
then please
um i already mentioned this to you
before pennington but um the agriculture
bill
right and that that was went through
the day in parliament yeah and i didn't
know if we could put that on the forward
plan
um at the end and maybe invite our mp
okay okay
that's right but that is very pertinent
i know because that was in uh debated in
westminster the um only on tuesday very
brightly
um and coaster ford sorry it doesn't it
doesn't only affect our farmers but also
consumers it affects everybody because
it's about our food standards
yeah uh true okay council ford
yeah yeah sorry about my uh chuckle
there i mean yeah i mean you're right i
think it'd be good to get the uh
get our mp there if he's not too busy
playing ron paul or bailly in his second
job i think you're absolutely right
because it's gonna be a very
important issue but just going back to
what country newton is a bit of where
where he's coming from and understand
but i think you've answered that all i'm
simply saying
is it has been instances
of this already in this council where
one or two councillors i believe have
acted
very close to the line whereby le verde
remark and then bought something to the
council what i wanted a boxing boat or
whatever
all i'm saying saying is and then they
use the word uh plethora of evidence
yes if you've got if you've got several
like you
said and i don't don't your work if
you've been approached by several people
about an item then you are duty-bound to
at least
act on that but if it's just a mate
that you're having a point with i would
say no what i'm getting now if you
generally got a plethora
a plethora greek origin means abundance
of evidence then you are duty
at least bring it up thank you thank you
ford um that discussed the idea many
further comments on that item
gender no good thank you very much
uh so we go forward to agenda item
number eight and
uh update please sean on the 1610
situation against the backdrop i hear
what's going on in cornwall today with
everything opening up be interesting to
hear what you got to say
thank you thank you i mean it's not an
awful lot i can
say other than to say that the
negotiations have progressed a little
we're moving towards preparing a report
for full council
and then obviously members will be able
to decide on
a way forward i would um just stress
that
we've been discussing a number of things
around finance
safety contractual liabilities all those
sorts of things
they've all been part of the negotiation
but i obviously can't give any detail of
that
because it will be discussed as a part
two full council agenda item
okay any questions to show on that
agenda item
i don't see any hands tom so we move on
yeah and there's no hands together thank
you very much right we now moved to
agenda item number nine
and i want to thank phil topham for all
his work our independent member on the
uh on this committee um he brought
forward a paper
um been working on that it's two and a
half years phil i think since you
started
yeah so um um can you lead us forward on
this agenda item please
certainly now check can i assume that
our council and colleagues have read the
documents that are
with the papers there most of which
you'll be familiar with from when we
discussed it
and about putting it in the annual
report i sort of assumed that everyone
would have read them
nobody's saying no they haven't read
them they're saying they haven't read
them
plus i'm just wondering they all seem to
be nodding
mr topham thank you very much i do
appreciate that
um okay i want to say a few words then
assuming you've read them
um you've got that summary in your
papers of the findings of the partner
evaluation form which is something we've
been trialing for the last 18 months
and with regard to the continuing use of
this form
i've suggested in my little paper that
there are four options
and there may be other options that you
want to propose
but one of them is to just continue with
the procedure as it is
with the forms being sent out to
partners after meetings
the second option is to not do it per
meeting
but send out annual evaluations to all
the partners who've been to meetings
and presented the third option
is to replace the partner evaluation
form
we've got a copy of it there with a
completely different method of
evaluation and the fourth one of course
is to abandon
evaluation altogether so
those that's that's the sort of core of
the discussion
that i i would hope that we could have
today
i'd like to draw your attention to a
couple of points
that both the original survey which was
an interview survey of about a dozen
partners
and by that i mean i went and talked to
them for about an hour
and made quite extensive notes about
their thoughts and feelings about the
committee and their relationship with it
but that survey but and also the
trial forms for the last 18 months did
make it very clear that partners
value the opportunity to share and
discuss their work
and their concerns with the committee so
that's a big plus
but at the same time they're also not so
convinced that what we say to them makes
much of a difference to how they operate
that may be less the case where we fund
them or whether it's a service level
agreement in place
and of course we wouldn't wish to manage
their work in detail
but they enjoy talking to us they
appreciate
us listening and careful questioning but
maybe it doesn't change much of how much
they do
and i think given that we were talking a
few weeks back about
where we can have an influence that's
probably uh finding to take note of
um so perhaps we need to clarify then
the nature and extent of the influence
that we wish to observe
and i think when you conduct an
evaluation like that and it throws up
um findings like that it is an example
of
evaluation is not a static process
it provides information about how our
partners see us and relate to us
but it also raises new questions which
we may
have or may not have the time and the
resources
to to explore the other point is that
partners are often unclear about what
happens as a result of
our discussions the presentations that
the meetings
and what we talk about with them and
they don't always feel that they're
informed or sufficiently informed about
recommendations and any subsequent
actions by the committee or council
so there is a view that if we're to
continue to conduct
evaluations in whatever form it's
important that we also have in place the
same procedure for
closing the communication loop between
the committee and
partners otherwise it just becomes
another administrative procedure
rather than the kind of living part of
the organization
so chair that's all i wanted to say i'm
happy to answer any questions
about the evaluation but as i say i
think there are there is particularly
four options to continue
whether whether or not to continue with
this and and in what form
right committee any questions to uh
independent member phil topham please
i have no hands going up at the moment
yeah councillor newton and councillor
cottle hunt can raise their hands
right country newton first please
bill thanks for that um
can i ask you phil in your um
process of of um research
do any other committees on torridge do
evaluation
i don't know the answer to that sorry no
i mean maybe one of the officers can
answer that but i don't know that
yeah did you know i'm not aware i mean
i think we all sit on stacey but stacey
might be more aware than me
but um i'm not aware of any other
committees that do
any evaluations like this as a routine
process yeah
okay thanks sean um phil nick follow up
on that if i may
uh the next one then is
do you have an example or evidence of
where
we have reacted to partner comment
or conversely evidence
of where partners have reacted to our
comment
uh there might be examples in the
interview
survey but remember i haven't been
conducting ongoing research
into partners responses we did the
interview survey
if you look at the last page of my
little report there's a
extract from the committee meeting by
this committee
and a number of recommendations that
were made
including um devising this evaluation
form yeah so there was no mandate or
suggestion that i should be involved in
any further research on the lines that
you
described but i will say just going back
to your first question
that it was precisely the matter of
influence and impact
that caused us to discuss doing this
whole thing in the first place
because we didn't know whether what we
were doing did have any impact or
influence
this is the intention i i
might have thought that perhaps with
hindsight
conducting a survey on
previous partners or partners that we've
dealt with
might have given us a clearer indication
of that um
it did the first survey did the original
survey did
yeah rather than rather than the use of
a form of a form like this um
i don't know the um
i'm i'm tempted to say that the
conclusion
of the work you've done phil the very
good work that you've done
and the results that we've got go
something like this as a committee
we're too nice we're too soft
nobody cares what we think we're not
challenging enough
when we do not shame underperformers
and therefore actually perhaps
we should be looking doing a bit of
navel gazing
and actually decide well whether what
what really
is our output and therefore our worth um
which has
come from all of this but i shall leave
that hanging there
like a good picture thank you
colonel honkin sorry sorry did you only
respond to that film
just uh just a quick one if i may uh not
to get into too much the finer points of
evaluation but
the interview survey where you ask
detailed questions
and the evaluation form which is an
ongoing
say you know mentally affair are two
different approaches to evaluation
one of the as you can see is much more
in-depth
but the the form that is given regularly
gives it
it has possibilities for sort of
quantifying information
that is it doesn't give you in-depth
qualitative information
and i mean that's something worth
considering that's why i put that as one
of the options that
you might want to conduct periodic
surveys
again if you have the time and resources
to do it in which case you can ask those
questions
and it might be that for example if you
did a big survey every year
you might come back and say actually we
haven't challenged our partners enough
this year
yeah exactly what we're saying so
okay cheryl cottle hunken please
um it sort of follows on from what
councilor newton was saying about
actions following the presentations
because the
lowest score if you look on them
the average scores the lowest one is
number seven where it says
about the recommendations and actions
following the presentation
and there's also a comment and
suggestion on page 16
where it says we would welcome the
opportunity to help deliver an event
with tdc
that explains more about the food and
farming industry to other members and
officers but i don't think that was
acted upon
so i do think it's really useful to have
these evaluations and maybe we need
need to act on them more
and put more actions into place so that
so that it's got more meaning really
so so there will be a more follow-up for
the the
situation um how would that
fit into the four options as uh phil has
given us cheryl
well i wouldn't want to see it abandoned
altogether because i think it is quite
useful
so you would be saying that you'll be
looking for option three which would be
replace
the paf with a different method so that
you're actually measuring the actions
that come out in the longer term
uh from that point of view would be your
review
so maybe continue with the evaluation so
partially part one and then maybe add to
it
with the actions okay uh councillor
forbes
sorry sorry yeah i don't know what other
members of the committee
think okay how's it before you hit your
hand up
yeah thanks chair um yeah again uh i'd
like to thank uh phil for obviously
putting a lot of hours on this
um and i think in some shape or form it
needs to continue whether it's annual
or going on option three as just uh
discussed by yourself and
uh councillor cole hankin but laura
would also
say uh again and i've said this in the
in the past
don't like keep repeating myself and
normally do that after 10 points of
cider
but um what i would say is again this
committee did do a hell of a good job i
think go to
the fire service and i think sometimes
um
it's nice actually for people to imply
that we're too nicer i'm too nice i've
never been
accused of that before but you know
occasionally we do get results
and again yeah be critical when we don't
but let's also stick our chest though
occasionally we do get results
thanks chair thank you very much like
comment counselor ford
uh coastal leather thank you jay
well yes i like all the thanks to phil
for the
piece of work he's done here it's a good
piece of work
but reading through the report and i
have read it all through
the other day i read it when when we got
the agenda
um i honestly don't think
it's worth continuing with it to be
frank
because what i'd like to see is when we
have when we have bodies come before us
and
partners come before us and of course
the ones that we do give grants to
uh are more likely to come and take
notice of us
than the ones that really complete
themselves whether they come or not
um i'd rather that after they've
been to one of our meetings and we've
discussed the issues
and maybe come up come up with some
recommendations i think
just a note to them saying
well they've normally seen the
recommendations they're still at the
meeting normally
but if they've not these are the
recommendations the committees made
we value we would value your comments
and feedback
and just leave it at that and if they do
comment and feedback fine if they don't
that's it but it's quite um
quite a piece of uh work to do this is
on a regular basis
and i'm not sure that i mean i think
counselor newton was right with what he
said here he summed it up
i i would agree with that view of it but
i do appreciate the work that phil's
done with this and as you said it was a
trial to see
how it went and for the for the few
few people we do have before us or
groups with your partners
i don't think this the office of time
and
the work taken in compiling this really
is worth continuing with
that's a very clear clear uh view thank
you very much council leather
i've got no further hands in front of me
at the moment uh
is that correct tom that is pretcher
thank you very much
um well i want to thank phil yeah sorry
councillor newton's now raised his hand
sorry carson newton sorry chap
um developing this further and just
looking
at at phil's um um
option three with a different method
i i i really do believe that
we should be more focused on the actual
issues at play
and strive to identify
actions and then have an automatic
review process where
somebody is nominated to go back to that
organization
say within 12 months to with
the questions or the actions that we had
noted in the meeting
to actually evaluate or report
on those actions uh at the end of them
at the end of a
a presentation or a dealing with a
partner
uh or an organization perhaps we should
produce an action sheet
which has at the end very clear crisp
um detail of what we torridge
are doing as a result of that that
meeting
and what the partner is going to do
and that so those are actions and then
we've got something to look at in the
future to
to get to measure it by to see whether
actually we've made progress first of
all have those actions been done
and secondly now that they've been done
have we
actually achieved progress or is it a
better uh
outcome um i just think it needs to be a
bit more
it needs to be sharper more targeted
and actually identifying the various
things
at the outset otherwise it gets lost in
a
in a very nice form where tick box where
people say that they've had a nice time
they haven't been
very heavily challenged and it was all
very nice
and some found it more useful than
others that actually isn't useful to us
so
because we need to have hard detail to
focus on personally i think
thank you okay i've got no further hands
at the present moment
okay i would just comment and thank phil
for
the work you're doing here on and the
ongoing work as well
um i'm just thinking through how how
we've
overviewed and scrutinied um various uh
things over the years councillor ford
mentioned the
fire service last year which was a
tremendous piece of work
jointly between uh councillor ford and
councillor hackett which
was very very impressive uh
interesting to see how on the council we
do work because where we have usually
service level agreements
we usually have a member who
works alongside i know i'm appointed now
alongside the cab
sometimes we have i think somebody from
tpvs where we
are funding um i can't remember who the
member is for the bernard gary sure
you're the member of the burton art
gallery
yes sir you're um yes sir now
interesting we have
those of you know people working
alongside various institutions that
we're funding
um and that is really good going uh from
that point of view
um and i also think about the wider
issues when we have our things like the
clinical commissioning groups and the
health services come in
um it is a huge issue sometimes and
and you feel very much like you're
scratching the surface um
but people do want to work with you um
and looking at the situation that uh
uh phil topples put before us um you
know you left us with four options here
i don't know if you want us to try and
come down to four options but um you've
got option three there where they
replace
the pef with a different method and i
just wondered if we should
couldn't identify a little bit clearer
where we get
good results and bad results so we
actually do part the
analysis more ourselves as well so you
know
take for instance um um talk about the
fire service um which was mentioned
already by councillors we could also
measure that from our side and see how
that effect and why that effect was
taking place
and how good it was the fire service
might have been very happy because
they didn't want to take part i think in
any of the discussions we had back at
the time
i think you said councillor ford that
they didn't want to send any
representatives if i remember rightly
that was correct wasn't it they didn't
send anybody to any of the meetings you
went to
where's the cord yeah yeah chair can you
hear me yes
yes i can i i think basically that is
largely true to be fair um
and we didn't actually even get anybody
from demon county council that was on a
fire thing uh turn up either
um again and again it's not about being
completely left or right here i'm not
interested in that whatsoever
but basically it didn't seem a great
deal of interest to engage at all
it seemed that it was almost like um
because history
it was a premeditated bit of work a
document was flawed in
thanks to uh you know this committee and
again i would think uh
well everyone in case of newton's input
with his suggestions because we did give
alternatives
that was a good bit of work we do
actually i'm saying you know i'm the
first one to criticize when there's you
know
recent criticize but that's pretty good
better work right
okay so what i'm trying to come to is
we've got sort of two
thoughts coming through from you as a
committee this evening okay
um as one i think was um voiced by
councillor leather
um and not to proceed with any further
because obviously there's a cost in time
um to do this um
and there was a value to and uh
to doing it uh to replace it with a
different method
um and i can quite see the logic
of doing it and the value of doing it
so long as we can identify where we're
strong and we're weak
that's where we're not i feel identify
what we're doing
so you've got i think a choice coming
between the two
and i just wondered if phil topham you
would consider
um you know asking a member of our
committee
to follow and champion uh a situation
say for the sire
fire service like we had the fire
service then ford does it
um where we're following an issue
through
um that we have a champion that actually
takes that and monitors
where the effect of what we're doing so
we have a measure
coming in from our side as well as those
that we are actually
scrutinizing i don't know how you feel
that phil
topham would fit in with your options
you presented us with that we may come
to decision now in a minute
okay can i just pull back a bit from the
options
scenario because i think the discussion
shows
that there is a principle here and that
is how much as an organization
is the council a kind of evaluation
culture
we do want to know whether what we do
has an impact
so the question of is how best to do
that right it was
it was interesting that um i remember
one or two of the people i interviewed
said how nice it was when their local
councillor came and popped in and talked
to them about
things of course that could be a bit too
friendly
but it might also it was suggesting that
they if they had that individual contact
perhaps as councilman newton was
suggesting you could explore
the impact of interventions and
decisions more thoroughly
so the question is maybe not so much
about
a form of evaluation but to what extent
do we conduct our affairs with what
effect is this having in our mind
yeah you see what i mean so rather than
just a procedure
you have a different mindset which is we
need to know
we need to be able to measure or assess
the impact of our
our consultations and decisions i think
that's what you're saying councilman
newton wasn't it
it's that principle um josh newton
please
and then coach connell honkin thank
thanks phil yes i mean uh and
picking up from from where the chair
left off just now
um perhaps we should
put it a different way i think it does
need a member of the committee
to take a personal interest in a
particular organization
after they have been and and presented
with us
uh it then and it helps
perhaps if there's a lead member on the
committee
or uh each organization as and when they
they come to us not not everything we
look at will
justify having a a twin with a a member
on the committee
but then at least we've got one one of
us who knows
that actually they've got to make it
their business to
get out there and and um
and have a close relationship with the
organization
so that we're in a position to monitor
and see what's happening
and perhaps also we can get more direct
feedback from them
that you'll probably get um in
conversation
than necessarily through a form to find
out actually the reality
of the impact we're having um and we
we may have more influence if we
actually did have somebody
who was tagged to these organizations as
they come through
uh so and it'd be easier for us to keep
in touch with them perhaps
uh just a thought thank you councillor
coddle honkin
i was just wondering whether we make the
form more specific to each of the
organizations
so you could include the recommendations
and actions that we've discussed at the
meeting
and put that on the form and then
when we get the response from them maybe
we could review it
at the next meeting after yeah
follow up and see if we've acted upon
the
recommendations and just to check that
we've actually followed it up because i
think sometimes things get lost
and we don't necessarily follow up what
we've discussed
with the partner all right thank you uh
sean kearney
thank you just picking up a point that
council newton make about
made about uh sort of tagging members to
to particular issues or organizations
i suppose theoretically we kind of got
that with the lead member roles
so we have a number of lead members over
a number a number of different areas and
i
i don't know whether it's the answer but
it's something for you to consider
perhaps
if you wanted to scrutinize something
and
it maybe you could invite a lead member
to update you as a committee as to what
our partner organizations feel about our
interactions with them
yeah just to jump in sean that the lead
members
are have oversight of functional areas
whereas here we're actually talking
about
accountability of organizations i think
it's a bit different
no no there are there are appointed
members that are linked to pacific
organizations
so so that um i think north devon plus
have got a couple of guys on the board
phil
um hackett and uh joe manley um uh i'm
with the cab
joe uh cheryl is with the um um
burton art gallery um so it's not just
the
league member row there is actually
appointed members
that work with these organizations which
is different from the lead member role
so so so we have that already in place
now whether
we could splice that on to the work that
phil topham has done here to make sure
that we then
feed back the base work we've done here
but then we get the ongoing evaluation
to make sure that we are getting effect
bang for a buck if you like that's what
we're trying to measure
um because there's a lot of bang but
there's no shot going out basically
that's what's happening
in the situation and we're trying to
measure how effective
what we're doing is is what we're trying
to do and that is an ongoing process
because
sometimes the effect is immediate
sometimes the effect is long-term but
the key
is to have that relationship with with
an organization that's key to what we
can influence isn't it
so i just wonder if if you replace it
with a different method
we have a base method here but we can
actually try to splice on
um the situation where we emphasize our
responsibility to remember to follow a
particular issue coming through
and we can refer back to that member to
bring real meaning to that form i don't
know how you
feel about that phil topham um to build
upon what you're
and you could work in line with that to
continue to monitor in a longer term
basis
from that point of view phil got your
hand up well
i saw this review as not only a decision
about methods but also decisions really
about whether the council wants to take
this on board
and own it in some way in which case it
does need to be attached to
the administration rather than a
volunteer i think
so you you want to place it with officer
rather than a member
uh situation
is that what i'm understanding you're
saying have i misunderstood
not necessarily me but i think if if
they're gonna
if the council's gonna commit to it then
they someone needs to
own the evaluation process as it were
and you are saying you're not prepared
to lead the evaluation process that's an
unfair question i apologize
i'm not i'm not going to be here forever
and that's what i say about an
evaluation culture if you're
if you've got a genuinely evaluation
culture you won't mind taking on
these things but particularly at present
time
it does involve time and resources so
there is an issue there
i appreciate there's an issue there so
okay interesting
to bring this then to a conclusion okay
we've got two lines of thought running
through here um
and either we go forward and build upon
what we have
or we say let's call it a day at the
present moment does the committee
disagree with that position i'm putting
forward we have those
it's a binary option we have either zero
or one
so we can make a way forward here before
we go forward phil
top him again sorry just just to make it
clear in case
i'm not emotionally attached to this so
i'm not going to be upset
i mean you're not going to be clear of
personal interest
well i've got personal interest it was
an interesting and i hopefully useful
thing to do but
i shall support the decision of the
committee
well well guys um um
the thinking coming through and hearing
the comments from coachella leather at
the
uh the beginning i i i didn't hear
a similar comment but there is merit in
what council leader said
um but here in the comments the other
way we seem to be
um going between three and four at the
present moment on the options
and i wondered if the committee wanted
to go to a vote on either one
with appointing a special mentor but
picking up phil topham's comment
and he's not going to be here forever um
most of our counselors won't be here
forever we've got one or two has been
here a long time and maybe too long
um as the situation may be and nobody
can guarantee what's what the future is
going to hold
um but you know there is merit in trying
to evaluate something
um to get the longer term point of view
to a certain extent
depends again on where the committee
thinks but we need to bring it to a
conclusion
um um and i wonder whether you would
obviously um you don't want option one
i don't see any favor for option one
which is continue with is it the present
moment
no sure yep council leather
thank you chair well i'd like to propose
that we do
abandon evaluation okay and i
i do value the feedback from the
the various groups and bodies that we do
have to scrutiny but i think we should
just send them
a brief note at the end of the process
asking them for any comments
and feedback they would like to give us
and then we would look at that
um but i think to have something as
in-depth in this
it's been a good trial period and an
interesting trial period
but i just think it's getting quite
bureaucratic to an extent
and the feedback should come naturally
from
whoever the nfu or whoever we have you
know
anybody like that okay they just should
feed back to us
we enjoyed being before you or we didn't
or we liked
this particular suggestion you've made
or recommended
so you would do it basically some of the
recommendations we make we can't
actually what's many of these groups to
take on board
let's then concentrate on a specific
motion you're putting forward their
council of leather that you not to
continue with
uh the the evaluation apart from sending
out a brief note
after the relevant organization has
appeared before the committee yeah is
that your
your your your proposition yes chad
right mary did you get that as a
proposition
a different proposition but you deal
with your second or first
if you could well do i have a second for
counselor a letters proposition
no i don't have a seconder so therefore
that proposition falls
so therefore country newton you have
another proposition
uh chair thank you i would propose that
we have we replace it with a different
method
along the lines of option three
which largely is based around
a nominated member who to
follow up over the period of the next
year
following a presentation it doesn't have
to be a long time
tie it can be a member who's appointed
from one presentation to the next
but we at least have somebody who knows
that they are going to follow up with
that organization
and report back to us over a period of
time
so i propose that we have we go to a
different method
um but linked to individual member
um who will follow up with an
organization um
so that we can keep an eye on on what's
happening
okay so mary is that too long a
proposition
no i've scribbled it all down you
scribbled it all down you're fantastic
good curser harding has got his hand up
are you
seeking the second or are you seeking i
would like to second
uh counselor um
newton's uh thing i think it's a good
idea if we do follow up and
someone does go along and find out what
the challenges are
and and report back right we have a
proposal
to cursor newton's motion uh secondary
councillor harding
are there any other propositions
i don't see any blue hands yeah can i
just ask though
who's going to be this individual well
we'll work that out after we get the
proposition through let's deal with
one's
one gate to one so i can't um go so
we'll never get anywhere let's deal with
the first one and then we will work out
who we're going to put in the second
place
okay i'll deal with the the further
issue then as it arises
kirsten langford thank you um i don't
think i'm gonna help you very much but
um i'm um i'm not really quite sure
what the best way to go is because i
actually i found this very valuable to
read these comments
um and um to look and so thank you for
that phil
um and actually i kind of feel that
to have to have the um a form like this
i mean if we're talking about looking at
relationships and building relationships
with organizations it's important that
they should be
able to say how they feel and also
it's important you know to see if we're
being effective
and we're seen to be effective and so
um although i didn't say i was for
option one at the time you raised
it um i i have found reading all this
quite valuable
um i do and i also agree though that
it's very useful to have that
personal contact of somebody going
having a link with an organization
um i suppose what i'm kind of saying is
i quite i quite like both
but um i don't suppose that's going to
be very popular
okay no i mean you're a committee member
and you
are taking what you're saying do you did
you want to propose that uh
you would go with option one that's your
you as a committee member you
you have a view um do you want probably
if you want my i think what i'm saying
is i i
actually found it valuable and um i
think it's important that organizations
should be
able to say how they felt about
something as well and i would
go for option one but add
um on that evaluation
um something about there being a link
counselor with that organization who
follows up a couple of times over the
year or something like that
so you're going option one plus a
counselor to carry responsibility to
follow up
i'm afraid i think i am yeah is that
okay to put that in your worksheet i'm
not i'll open a words in your mouth okay
but uh no no no no that is how i feel
thank you
for you okay so you've got a proposition
any secondary or
second of the sheriff caller honking
you've got your hand up sorry
yeah i agree answer langford i think i
do
i find it really useful as well but i
think with councillor newton's
added to that gives even more meaning to
it
and it allows more feedback to the
committee as a result
so so which way are you going cheryl are
you going with uh
the second proposition or the first
proposition well the first one was both
wasn't it
um i mean council langford if um
we continue this but on top of that have
a nominated person
for each um partner or
organization to feedback as well as
having the evaluation for
right okay proposal wasn't it that was
council langford's proposal was to go
with option one
but to add a person to go alongside
and mary can you read out the
proposition from councillor newton so
that we
can make sure we know what we're voting
on yet
we're running our
so councillor newton's proposal was that
replace it with a different method
um along the lines of option three
mm-hmm
the person that um responsibilities yes
yes
with a nominated member to follow up
over the period of the next year
okay so the two differences in the
propositions coming forward from
councilman newton
is he's taken replace the pdf with an
additional
uh follow-up with a nominated member
correct i like getting you correct here
country newton
is continue with the present form
because you value
the scores you're getting back from the
various organizations
but you add a person to go alongside to
make sure
that we follow up and get value um
of the evaluation so that's the two
different values of the properties we've
got
on the table do you understand we've got
two pro
and i've got a seconder for coaching
langford from counselor coddle honking
how am i correct in that
call country color again yeah i was also
wondering if she'd add
um so as well as nominating someone
or someone putting their name forward to
follow up whether we
also include the recommendations that
were made just so it's clear to the
organization
the recommendations that were made as a
result of the meeting
are you happy for that council langford
to add to your
proposal um yes yeah
that's fine good so that addition to
that proposal so is there any you can't
be many more left of
to um put a proposition for you there
guys so uh we've got two to vote for
okay so we take the first
proposition first which was from
councillor newton seconded by councillor
harding that we take
option three and replace the pef
um with something with a different
method
um but um we then also attach somebody
to follow up from that point of view
so can i ask for those in favor
of that proposition please can you take
a vote please mary
yes chair councillor coddle honking
against
hawkins against
councillor langford against
councillor against
council newton four
thank you so chair that's three four
five against and one abstention okay
yeah so therefore the emotion is lost
and we now come to the second proposal
which was
proposer councillor langford second by
councillor carl hunken
that we continue with the evaluation it
is with the addition of a responsible
member
plus the recommendations are going to
the committee at the end of each meeting
that's correct guys isn't it of your
proposition so therefore mary
we go to the second vote
again he keeps freezing
before everybody votes on that on one
i know i notice it's not exactly the
same as we as has been done it's
it's sending online evaluations to each
presentation
okay well let's deal with the
propositions where we are cursed leather
at the moment and then we can
we've got in principle where we are we
can then build forward for the future
okay
so we've got now the um the uh
proposal and second of the motion from
councillor langford and councillor cotto
so mary can you just go to the vote here
please first
councillor coddle honking
councillor ford
council afford he's just reconnecting
mary
okay should i come back oh he said he's
back now councilman
council afford like um
can you hear me now yes yeah yeah i've
just got a birthday
song left to leave i've got 11 year old
birthday here just turned up here anyway
but i'm four
four thank you councillor harding
abstain
thank you councillor hawkins at four
councillor langford for
councillor leather against
councillor newton freight this is even
more work
so against i'm afraid councillor
pennington
and i'm gonna go against as well yes
mr topham abstain
chair that's four four
three against and two
the bushing abstentions carried so
therefore
we then will affect that from that point
of view phil
um thank you for your work um
and uh to follow on from here um
we will continue to monitor how this
will change to a different method
um next question is are you up to
looking at how to change that to a
different method
uh i'm happy to work with someone yeah
to revise the form and
procedure that's fine then
um does anybody want to work in this
situation
i am happy to volunteer as chair of the
committee obviously
um although i've voted against the the
proposition there um
and any other volunteers
uh council caller honking yeah i'd be
happy to as well
okay yeah are you happy with a
couple of us very happy very happy
if i can help at all as well i'm i'm
happy to as well
so okay okay this form would stay the
same though didn't we
it was just adding the recommendations
specific to that meeting
and having someone to follow
okay so we can send them an email
uh phil and begin to look at the way
forward from this meeting and see how
that takes its course
yeah thank you very much committee any
further comments on that agenda item
good i know uh council langford sorry
um can i just say that is that is there
any mileage
in the the
you probably say no but is there any
mileage in the counsellor that
is going to be the link counselor
being responsible for dealing with the
form
and then feed as cheryl said earlier on
feeding back to the next meeting so it
becomes very immediate
um as well as linking do you see what
i'm saying
i see what you're saying yes i think
that it's very valid
um and i think that is to be done in the
mechanics of how we actually put this
together
uh and uh i think that we just need to
work this one through now
to to to um um make sure that the
the work is done and um and we monitor
that
and part of the interesting how the vote
went
um it is going to be the cost of time as
well that we have to be very careful
about as well
from that side so uh yeah from we will
certainly get that going forward and
feedback
at the the next meeting
okay we go forward now to the
consideration and issues brought forward
by the committee
um i i i haven't seen this
item on the agenda before um but i
linking this in to with the
item agenda item number 11
considerations for the forward plan
because they seem to be the two same
items together
am i allowed to do that stacy
yeah yeah it is okay
okay so so i'm linking agenda item 10
and 11 together
um because the issues we're going to you
should be to consider now is the things
that we're going to factor forward plan
so we are here um and you have a copy of
the forward plan which is the big cheap
attached um um i have a copy of the
sheet here but you've got a copy of
it doesn't go very well on on ipad does
it unfortunately when you look at the
ford plan
have you got a good copy of the four
plans in front of you everybody
i'm fortunate because mary sent me out a
um
is an a5 or a3 size sheet but certainly
it gives me a good
easy view of the timetable can you see
it clearly before i start
yeah nobody's saying otherwise good
right our timetable we've got the
extraordinary special meeting on the
18th november
play strategy draft okay so that is in
its place that's what we'll be looking
at
sean you've got the timetable to get
that out um for us to have a good
read before we get going at the meeting
sean
sorry chair i'm moving between ipads a
bit awkward only because i'm i'm
swapping between screens i'm obviously
not very fluent with this method but
yeah no problem at all we're all good
for for november to have a draft play
strategy
okay janet are we okay for the
community safety partnership joint with
north devon this is a week
later 2 p.m um um
with joint north devon um is that all up
and running
from your point of view i'll have to
check with uh
mary but uh certainly uh toby davis has
been advised of that date
um and he is available so um
uh we'll get that uh confirmed with you
as soon as we can
chair um we need to confirm a venue
is it with us i think it's north
devlin's turn this time they were with
us last year i think if i'm rightly
what would be doing it remotely no oh we
do
really of course we are gonna say
why am i dreamland here for goodness
sake and just following on from that one
um comment after the meeting last year i
think toby davis said
to me that he would like to send her
some stuff beforehand this
he got stuff that he's going to
obviously send us for pre-reading
um and and explain more in detail what
the community safety partnership was
because i think it was
six months into a new council and i feel
from toby davis's point of view
he didn't feel um we as under understood
as counselors
our role as is the scrutiny and overview
of scrutiny
that's fair enough chair and we've got a
community safety partnership meeting
next week so i'll be seeing toby then so
i'll
speak to him about that and we'll get
something out to members before the
meeting
and is phil hackett our lead member on
that
he is indeed yes he's on that committee
so he can feed back to us as well
absolutely phil has always been a good
uh servant of this committee so he'll
feed back into us
from that point of view right we come
then to the 20th of january
and you see a blank space on your
forward plan
but it was proposed um you know the
about the issues around the end of the
furlough scheme and it comes back to our
public speaker this evening ben
nye um talking about
his very specific issue um i've
mentioned
the issues going on in the countryside
and the shakedown
between and i just wonder whether we
could not widen that and link that in
um to ca being invited um
to to talk about issues of rent arrears
debt and
all the other um personal circumstances
that people will be facing
and the work that they will be doing um
and linking into the wider community and
i just wonder whether you'd be
interested in
adding that to the um 20th january
meeting
so i leave that for you ask your advice
as a committee
whether you you would consider
looking at the the business and um
structural issues that are happening in
some of the hospitality businesses that
are happening around your area
yeah yeah sorry can i can i just
because you can yeah and and just
actually
um following on from the comments that
you you made earlier and the concerns
um one thing that you you might find
handy
or helpful what to listen to as a
committee is the work that we're doing
alongside
encompass um and it feeds directly into
the issues that you're saying
regarding the cab and the other wider
community issues now
encompass have been assisting torridge
with
ministering the hardship grant yeah and
hardship payments and the reason they've
been assisting is because very often
they're having the people approach them
who
who are struggling because of covid or
had a financial impact because of covid
um so we've partnered up with them and i
i was wondering
if that's something that members might
be interested in listening to
and because their spectrum is far wider
than what forwards are doing
and they're doing a lot of good good
work within the community
and directly on the front line when it
comes to the co-fed
um situation so i haven't approached
them yet
just thinking about it off the cuff but
i've certainly been very impressed with
the work that they've been doing and
what they've done
with porridge thus far so that might be
um something that members would like to
to um
listen to and and discuss with with
encompass and i could
perhaps approach them if if and ask if
they were
um happy to attend and and have that
discussion
i'm very happy for for for that to
happen i don't know if anybody has a
view simon newton councilman newton
um thanks chad uh yeah i mean because
really
what we're looking at is
um a session to look at the economic
impact of convid or furlough or or
any any any any constituent part of the
coveted um pandemic
now we can't look at everything because
we'd be swamped but
to pick certain um organizations of
which i think stacy has come up with a
good one like that
who can actually give us a flavor um
and and give us some actual ground truth
of of of detail of what is actually the
impact
um i don't think we can selectively
pick individual um
[Music]
so uh cases because otherwise
we need to be we need to be looking
across the piece
generally but um yeah i would have
thought that the title of that
um that meeting perhaps is the the
economic impact of the pandemic
um and then looking at
various barometer organizations
who can actually um give us um
an indication as as to where we're at
um stacy's come up with one i'd need
people
better place than i to advise me on
others but that's what i'd suggest chad
well okay so i'm happy
you're in favor of what stacy suggested
anybody else has to come i don't see any
other blue hands going up in front of me
at the moment
uh closer leather well yeah we could
include the cab couldn't win with that
well i think we've already got that in
our minutes it does say on page
10 of them and it's that was actually
proposed but wasn't put into the forward
plan
actually at the time ttvs would have a
view on that as well
that's the very comment i was going to
say counselor leather
i didn't realize your mind was just is
in the same way as mine
i'm learning all the time here from that
from that side um i wonder whether we
could also ask a local representation
from the federation of small businesses
for the area to come and have a a
a join here um and uh put a brief
presentation of how the situation has
affected them um
and is there a north devon branch or um
and the other one was the biddeford
chamber of commerce
yes i think i think you'd be better with
encompassing ttvs and
cab that'd be plenty to here
give us a very good overview of what's
happening there i should call honking
got your hand up
this this was separate from the covert
situation it was about inviting our mp
particularly on food standards
right um
i think given the um given where we are
at the present moment i don't know if
we can squeeze that in given the size of
it but is there anybody who would want
to support
counselor call hook in there just at the
present moment on the
effective agriculture bill
brexit might have happened by next
january you never know that could be for
a later meeting maybe it could be a
later meeting yeah i accept that for a
later meeting totally accepted for a
later meeting
but going back to to to the 20th of
january we're going to restrict it i
feel
coming from the meeting that the
invitations going out to
a compass was suggested by stacey um
uh our solicitor there uh ttvs
and the cab so that we've got three
grassroots
storage organizations that can give us
some real insight of the effect
i know that both ttvs and cab send out
quarter returns to us
are very very informative and maybe we
ought to keep our eyes open when they
come through again just to keep the
background from there
so if we can make that our january
meeting and you will agree to that
we will make that the plan for the
january meeting are you all happy
sure otherwise neither see any blue
hands
ah we have mr topham uh
yeah just going back to mr nye at the
beginning were we not going to
discuss him with regard to the forward
plan
well we certainly can but the meeting i
suggested we bring in small business and
otherwise
but the meeting was in favor of
narrowing it down i didn't want to focus
surely on the palladium
um which i think you're talking about
because
he's very eloquently talked about the
valuable service it does to benefit but
i think we need to be a wider
situation though from the meeting
here well i suggested we went wider fsb
and organizations but the meeting didn't
want to do that
um so so at the moment i can't bring
that on
um from the point of view of being
focused of what your wishes were but if
you want to
um look at something from business i
don't think we can look at the palladium
but i think we can certainly look at fsb
or or something like that but i don't
think there's a flavor
to do that from the present moment from
the meeting bear in mind that i'm
going to follow up with mr nye tomorrow
or not tomorrow but certainly
to see how tourists can best meet um
with
cheryl and myself we've already agreed
to do that haven't we cheryl
you converted to me you agree with that
you know
that exactly what they need and
whether we can discuss the full council
um like if it was
new premises or whatever it is because
we don't know the details yet
okay so we have that in hand okay that's
fine
and we won't be lost by what he said and
i feel the meeting saying
concentrate purely on three
organizations cab
and compass ttvs and not widen it
so i i think there's nods coming from
you're all there
please show otherwise uh mr topham used
to hansel
do you want to say again no i just say i
wasn't trying to
widen the brief i was just checking that
we had got some kind of response to him
yeah that's absolutely fine right i
don't see any blue hands
then we go forward to the 10th of march
and um we do
have a show just inform us that we've
spoken with westwood housing and they're
going to come to this meeting that we've
asked
um unfortunately they could not attend
tonight they
did they did send their apologies um i'm
unable to attend
yes mary's been in contact with them
okay
um and um they will be with us and they
have assured us they will be with us
which was your wish
they will be with us for the 10th of
march if there's anything
further you want to add we can add that
at the future meetings
any further comments committee
none hang on
sorry
yes philip topham yes item 11.
to review the forward plan and consider
how the committee looks at preparation
thereof
when it has no power to instruct
external partners to attend
are we going to address that last phrase
oh yes
yes i've forgotten that good job you
reminded me
um that's the weakness when we have only
a single item agenda
i i put that in myself thank you for
reminding me of that before i was
rushing on
um um it just emphasizes that if we go
for a single item
the powers we have as overview and
scrutiny
external is that we can only invite we
don't have the power
to to um um
they have to attend as though if they
were a member as
internal could ask an officer of the
account so to attend
we don't have that same power and we are
slightly vulnerable if we are focusing
on such
focus that when somebody cannot attend
and if you remember last year
16-10 didn't attend one of the meetings
as well
um that can throw the meeting off course
i er is something to consider when we
put our agenda together
um i think we're fairly clear um for the
next two meetings
but i think it's something we should
bear in mind as a committee if we just
do a single item agenda
and it doesn't work out and that was why
i put that on there
and it will be something that we need to
remember
in a lesson to this evening maybe that
westwood couldn't attend when we had
that on the agenda
does that answer your question phil
thank you
okay are you all happy with that answers
guys
yeah i think stacey stacy dory
stacy hey chad um
just and to make your meeting as
productive as possible
and when we send the invites out um our
members looking for the situation as it
is on the ground how they found
um torridge um after the furlough scheme
ending
issues that they um had raised with them
sort of so so you can
really get a flavor of what's going on
it
you know i'm clearly inviting compass to
come but i'm wondering
what sort of issues members would like
to kind of know the details
about i'm presuming it's the financial
impacts and
um the approaches they've had since
furlough ending that that sort of
subject well i suspect given the
the work of encompassed cab and ttvs
they are very much involved um
at the grassroots of um
of not business side but the employee
side the tenant side
and you're going to be looking at issues
around the rent arrears
you're looking at debt you're looking at
um
i suppose business opportunity and
employment law will be going by the
window
but i mean if you read the gab and
reports
um they will indicate which is the top
welfare issues that come
forward um ttvs will be very much the
same and the compass i should imagine
comes very much
so it will be very much from the the
grassroots side of residence of torridge
not the business side of storage
which um you know you're not going to be
looking at those who actually run the
businesses you're going to be actually
looking at those who are affected
because they're no longer working
uh from that side and that's where i
think the remit is it's going to be
is is is looking at ordinary residents
and how they've
been affected and it will be then 10
months into the culvert process um
and uh fertile schemes may still be
going who knows i mean maybe in
tier three who knows um just
pray everybody keeps well that's all we
can do from that side but that's where i
think the focus will be
and what we're asking the three we've
chosen
their um client groups that they're
working with and they're all gonna be
client groups that are struggling to pay
the council tax 25
their rents and it's going to impact on
our homelessness
uh requirement which we have a statute
of responsibility for
so it's a real linking to what we're
doing in storage as well so is that
clear enough answer to you
from yeah that's
that's how i understand it i just didn't
know there's any other pacific issues
that members
or any other details specifically that
members would would like to hear about
so i can
um try and make it as um
informative for you as possible but
you're quite right chair that that's why
we're
um working alongside encompass um
because it links
in with our homeless service issues um
etc
as well but you know and from toronto's
perspective obviously we can give
information on that and then compass can
give a wider perspective because they
are
are seeing a lot more issues than now
coming through towards this door but
i didn't know there was any um specific
issues
the laws sorry council laws sorry stacy
cut you off then
um yeah um thank you for letting me
speak because i'm i'm not a member of
this committee
uh it just concerned me this is going
sort of back one step uh where we
have contracts with shall we say 1610 as
an example
who failed to turn up for one meeting
within their contracts should it not
require them
to given a sufficient notice to attend
meetings
because uh if a situation arose where
they were stalling or
people we were dealing with were
stalling or just didn't want to justify
something to us by not attending you're
putting it back at least one
cycle and it's just not business like
right can i just answer that question
because there's a
the 1610 failed did not fail to attend
um there was a confusion in the way the
invitation went
and it was crosswire somewhere and there
was no
refusal for them that they didn't
actually refuse to attend from that
situation
and westwood housing tonight um
for tonight's meeting um there was just
nobody available for them to come
tonight now both organizations weren't
deliberate in being up um awkward
it's that they're they have
organizational responsibilities
and sometimes things go amiss um all i'm
saying is when those situations arise
and you have a single item
that's your focus of agenda um that does
have an
impact sometimes on on the working of
this committee that's all i'm saying
it goes back to my previous comments so
i wouldn't want to cast aspersions
on 1610 from that point of view or
westwood from not attending tonight it's
just the way it was
but when it comes to casting the floor
plan it just reminds us of the power
that we have as a committee
to instruct people or not to instruct
people um if you were internal if you
asked the
torch district council office to attend
i understand they would be retired
required to attend um which is the power
that internal have but we have no power
to ask any organization
from outside the to attend they can
actually refuse so that's the way it is
um so there's no aspirations on 1610
or westward from that point of view it's
just how our committee
forward plan fits into place i hope that
answers your question
prince little yes it does but it doesn't
satisfy me i'm afraid
all right time may tell ah
i think if you're if you have a contract
it's four inches
deep somewhere in there it should say
if required given one month's notice we
would like you know you have to
thank you chair well there you go that's
um
[Music]
interesting comment okay it's not on the
agenda item tonight so we can't vote on
that one
coaching a leather yes thanks chet
on the january meeting then besides any
financial implications
i also was thinking about the mental
health aspects of what's been happening
to the population of torridge uh through
job losses not through contracting any
illnesses but
the the wider issues of what's been
going on
really that's what i'd like to hear
from the three attendees not just the
financials
not being able to pay the rent or
council tax
but the wider effects that that's what's
been happening these last few months
has had on the population of torridge
any recommendations that this committee
are able to make then
to torres district council of any way we
think we might be able to
use our best endeavors to help more than
we are doing
that's really what i was thinking about
with that okay so we're not talking
about just quantitative
data about how domestic abuse has been
on the increase in
in homes with people stuck at home and i
appreciate it so so can
i ask for some qualitative stories to
come alongside the
quantitative data that these
organizations of the economy and the
loss of jobs
right businesses that have folded and we
heard about one threatened tonight
earlier on
you know it's been absolutely criminal
what's happened in the country i think
it's
newton sorry i was just coming back on
cancer laws's point on the contractual
side of it
councilors we we do put that um as a
point in our contracts and then all our
service level agreements if we're
funding um so it would be a requirement
that they
attend contract meetings with us and
and of course we could request that they
attend committee
if that satisfies um the question
thank you i should never have doubted
you stacy
question newton i'm just going to say
that um
councillor leather there was saying
that's all part of the economic
impact um by by calling it
imp economic impact doesn't mean that
we're just talking
money we're talking the whole a whole
gambit
however we've got to be quite selective
as to what we look at
otherwise we'll we'll we'll just scratch
the surface of lots of things and not
look at anything proper
and actually not come away with you know
a real
hard feel for what's going on and we're
looking at cutting away the political
crap and actually looking at what's
really happening on the ground
in in the most affected end of the
community
um so i'm just cautious about
widening it with too many organizations
it'll then turn into a circus and we
won't
we won't do anything properly i think
we've already decided we're inviting the
cab
and compass ttvs that's what we've
agreed
and can we ask that they just
because stacy stacy was asking
the remit what rematch she's got to ask
these to cover and it isn't just
economic or financial it is the much
wider issues
of the effect that these three bodies
can tell us about
and bring to us i think we're pretty
cognizant of a lot of them ourselves
but you know if we're going to make any
meaningful recommendations
after we've heard from them it does need
to to
be a pretty broad brush of what things
they've come across
that we may be able to help with and
have an impact on
then can i satisfy you both then by
saying that we ask the three
organizations to come with some
qualitative
um evidence i.e stories about how
the impact somebody's lost their home
somebody's had the bayless calling
somebody's had the electric cut off
whatever
um so that you can see the effect of
that um
but if we widen it too far you've got
the situations proposed by council
newton
so can we agree as a committee that we
keep it to the three organizations
and they add some flesh to the
pure economic bones of what the actual
impact means of somebody who might be
losing their house you know i mean
i can't think of anything worse than if
you are now facing the eviction notice
but been protected for the time being
from the government
and um um
[Music]
we can ask the these three organizations
to give some qualitative evidence
to support the what i think will be very
sad
quantitative evidence are you happy with
that committee
please show otherwise i've got no stacy
dory here with her hand up please
i'm a little bit late again um but but
just following on from council ever
was was right i i think and the reason
that i
made that suggestion was because
obviously we're still unclear
as to the full effects of covert and
what's it
you know the effect it's going to have
on our economy and
um to people personally
and actually i i felt that if a compass
or organizations like that came forward
explained what they're seeing on the
ground it would then give members a
better
idea as to where best to allocate the
resources
um and and actually if you want to hear
about the stories
because they are seeing it and dealing
with it day in day out they're seeing it
far more than torridge
district or or george offices are so it
would give you a greater insight and
then
um as members you could decide where
best to allocate resources and help
thank you phil topham please
yeah just a suggestion on procedure i
remember we had the
farm national pharmacy union i can't
remember his name and we had andy bell
for the birthday
butler andrew butler and andy bell from
biosphere
they were going presentation and they
did a joint presentation and i thought
that was very useful because
they we were party to the dialogue
between them
as well as hearing them present to us
and i wonder if
bearing in mind what has been said about
trying to get
you know a fairly in-depth political
picture
whether at least part of the meeting we
might enable
representatives of those three
organizations to be
doing things doing something jointly and
that's exchanging views between
themselves
just a suggestion well certainly i think
that could be part of the evening you
know part of the uh
is an evening is it it's not um yes this
is 6 p.m on on the 20th of january
talking about now yes i certainly think
that um
they they bring such insight they'll be
very similar
are you okay with that answer so you
know what you're
saying to encompass stacey
you you have i answered your question is
your question
yeah right no for other hands
no more items on the agenda i'm now
going to declare the meeting closed at
1950. so thank you very much
for your attendance thank you everybody
for your work in all the work you're
doing in your communities it's uh
sad times we live in and thank you for
all you're doing good evening to you and
good night